[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit heinz
wolf uns marietta slomka
guten abend in exakt drei wochen werden
wir um diese zeit über hochrechnungen
und ergebnisse reden und kein mensch
kann im moment sagen wie die sache
ausgeht vielleicht wird man das auch am
sonntagabend in drei wochen noch nicht
wissen so knapp könnten die zahlen seien
so unklar die konstellationen
interessant ist wie sich die wahlkämpfer
im schlussspurt justieren und auf scholz
etwa trommelt jetzt für eine rot-grüne
koalition
das wäre natürlich am schönsten dann
drückte sich die lästige frage nach dem
dritten beziehungsweise der dritten im
bunde über solche zweier fantasien hätte
man bei der union vor wenigen monaten
auch laut gelacht und sie als utopien
abgetan nach lachen ist im laschet lager
aber derzeit wohl keine mehr zumute
nicola albrecht berichtet vom heutigen
wahlkampf sonntag als gespräch am
gartenzaun 75 minuten ganz persönlich in
intimer runde deswegen auch gleich per
du so wurde die diskussion mit den
beiden kanzlerkandidaten scholz und
baerbock aus potsdam in einem kino in
babelsberg inszeniert angekündigt als
das duell wie es bei dir hattest du
schon mein garten stellte sich schnell
eine recht harmonische atmosphäre in
sonntäglicher kleingarten idylle ein und
die duellanten setzen überwiegend auf
gemeinsamkeiten vor allem bei
familienpolitik und sozialer
gerechtigkeit
weil wir erlebt haben dass menschen in
den pflegeberufen in sozialen berufen im
supermarkt alles gegeben haben die
gesetzlichen mindestlohn von 12 euro
einzuführen das passt gut also erstens
bin ich für einen gesetzlichen
mindestlohn von 12 euro und auch im
ersten jahr der nächsten regierung
beflügelt vom aktuellen umfrage hoch für
ihn und seine partei macht scholz keinen
hehl daraus die grünen sind in seinen
augen ein willkommener koalitionspartner
wenn die spd nummer 1 bleibt und da ist
er der einzige moment in dem baerbock
auf distanz geht wenn die echte
veränderung brauchen und wollen dann
muss grün ganz vorne mit dabei sein weil
sonst ist es wie klima ohne schutz und
das wird uns in die sackgasse platz zwei
ist ja auch ganz vorne anna lena
das könnt ihr ja noch miteinander
verhandeln ein kontrastprogramm zum
kinotag absolviert er an diesem
wahlkampf sonntag armin laschet noch
einmal besucht er die von der
flutkatastrophe betroffenen gebiete in
seinem bundesland nordrhein-westfalen
dicht an seiner seite kanzlerin merkel
und auch wenn es offiziell kein
wahlkampf termin sein soll ihre
unterstützung ist wohl willkommen denn
der kanzlerkandidat der union steckt
derzeit im umfragetief hinter scholz
bemüht vor ort näher herzustellen kommen
am ende die betroffenen bürger nicht
wirklich nah an ihn ran laschet der top
krisenmanager das soll denn noch heute
hängen bleiben wir haben heute die erste
brücke
gesehen die wieder funktionsfähig ist
und das nach wenigen wochen das war
möglich weil wir nordrhein westfalen ein
planungsrecht haben das sehr sehr
unbürokratisch ohne
viele vorschriften ermöglicht hat
einfach zu beginnen und zu starten und
so resümiert schließlich auch die
kanzlerin armin laschet führt dieses
größte bundesland der bundesrepublik
deutschland sehr erfolgreich und wer so
ein land führen kann kann auch die
bundesrepublik deutschland als kanzler
für
koalitionen konstellationen und das
kanzleramt wer gewinnt 21 tage vor der
wahl noch offen
darüber wollen wir mit markus söder
sprechen guten abendessen da
man sich die umfragen ansieht oder auch
die werte speziell für armin laschet
dann sind sie jetzt eigentlich in einer
blöden situation sie können sich selbst
nachhinein bestätigt fühlen aber freuen
dürfen sie sich darüber ja nicht nein
ich freue mich gar nicht ist zum einen
wert ist schnee von gestern
und zum anderen geht es ja ums land und
nicht um die person und man muss hier
die folgen diskutieren die umfragewerte
sind in der tat nicht gut und besitzt
auch schon in trend zu brechen die
nächste woche ist da jetzt ganz
entscheidend da muss der trend gebrochen
werden er muss wieder nach oben gehen
für uns und es geht im endeffekt nur
wenn man noch mal auf die konsequenzen
hinweist was eine kanzlerschaft von olaf
scholz vor allem der konstellation mit
den linken und den grünen bedeuten würde
nämlich am ende das gleiche wie damals
bei gerhard schröder am ende steht
arbeitslosigkeit und eine hohe
verschuldung ja das ist jetzt diese rote
sacken rote socken schlager der wieder
rausgeholt wird sie haben doch vor
kurzem im interview mit der sz selbst
mal gesagt keiner will die alte union
aus den neunzigern zurück ist das nicht
jetzt auch von altes rezept mit dem man
es verzweifelt noch versucht der aber
viele wollen auch eine die alte linke
ich meine schauen sie es gibt schon noch
sehr viele menschen in deutschland die
sich darüber ärgern und betroffen sind
dass teile der linken nach wie vor nicht
in der lage sind zu erklären dass die
ddr ein unrechtsstaat war oder teile der
linken und einzelpersonen werden vom
verfassungsschutz beobachtet wollen wir
denn wirklich eine regierung haben mit
der regierungsmitglieder drin sind von
einer partei die mit dem
verfassungsschutz war da also das thema
spielt schon eine große rolle und
verzeihen sie mir wenn ich das sage man
muss ja mal sehen am freitag war das
team lasche das vorgestellt wurde was
ist denn eigentlich das team stolz wer
steht dahinter auch westen spricht vom
demokratischen sozialisten das könnte
man
die zusammen wer ist eigentlich team
laschet also bei denen die da auf der
bühne standen da kann für die breite
öffentlichkeit herrn merz den rest nicht
wo waren sie da wo war da herunter oder
herr kretschmar aus sachsen warum stand
wieder nicht alle ja es ging auch ein
spezielles fach team das da war dass die
gesamte union hinter armin laschet steht
und jetzt zusammenhält ist doch ganz
klar es ist auch nicht die zeit für für
feinheiten an der stelle sondern es die
zeit ist auch für gemeinsamkeit und das
ist auch ganz wichtig dass wir noch
einmal die herausforderung darstellen
ich weiß dass das der ein oder andere
nicht so gern hört aber ich glaube schon
dass ein kanzler scholz olaf scholz ist
sicherlich einer fahne finanzminister
völlig unbestritten war auch ein
erfahrener bürgermeister aber die
wahrheit ist doch dass das ganze team
die sich dann in der breite auf stellt
festen herr kühn hat aber auch anton
hofreiter und die linke also das ist
schon etwas macht dann jeder wissen
geschwister zu kommen das ist jetzt
alles negativ kampagne was sie machen
also das ist doch einfach immer nur auf
die gegner beschossen sollte nicht
versuchen herr lastet lieber für sich
ein thema zu finden das jetzt positiv
nochmal nach oben zieht ja natürlich
gehört es auch dazu es gehört auch dazu
dass wir uns noch mal mit den eigenen
themen beschäftigen den vordergrund
rücken das zb entlastung wichtig ist für
die bitte für alleinerziehende wie wir
es bei uns im programm haben für den
mittelstand für handwerker
beispielsweise das für mich ganz wichtig
alle reden in deutschland über die
steuern der konzerne keiner redet über
die wirklich so genannten kleinen die
vielen vielen selbständigen unserem land
die von bürokratie und hohen steuerlast
betroffen sind und wir müssen natürlich
auch darüber reden wie wir in
deutschland was das thema wohnen
betrifft vorankommen ich bekam ich das
ganze programm vorlesen ich lese sie
nicht vor ich jetzt ja
ich will es aber schon mal sagt zum
beispiel beim beim wohnen wenn sie
wieder erlauben da gibt es ja auch
unterschiedliche modelle also das
berliner modell also direkt der des
senats war ja eher in die enteignung ich
würde wohnungen zu bauen es ist ein
verfassungsgericht ja auch abgelehnt
worden ja aber da sehen sie mal was die
botschaft ist das eine wird vom
verfassungsgericht abgelehnt wir wollen
den anderen weg geht zum beispiel
wohngeld erhöhten gesagten sie aber
selbst heutzutage ist es ein kandidat
der die partei zieht und nicht die
partei den kandidat werden sie jetzt
kandidaten stände die union anders da
bundesweit ich glaube in bayern würde ja
warum das war schon besser abstand das
weiß ich nicht das kann man jetzt spielt
auch keine rolle das ist ja alles so
verstehen sie hätte hätte fahrradkette
das spielt überhaupt keine rolle jetzt
gilt es in diesen entscheidenden stunden
einen linksrutsch zu verhindern das ist
glaube ich das gebot der stunde und
jeder muss halt einfach wissen worum es
geht jetzt auch kein negativ kampagne
ist es einfach nur alternativen
aufzeigen dass die bürgerliche
alternative und es gibt eine linke und
ich kann war noch nicht richtig
vorstellen dass wirklich ganz
deutschland nach links will im moment
sieht es aber so aus als würde zumindest
dass die spd vor der union landen und
dann im politbarometer sich die zahlen
anguckt ganz interessant 60 prozent
würden zwar auch keinen linksbündnis wie
sie es nennen wollen also rot grün rot
aber die gleichung 657 prozent sagen
auch als jetzt vor der wahl das
ausschließen es eigentlich gar nicht
nötig der wähler kann schon auch
strategisch taktisch denken ja ist schon
recht also man die zahlen sind da es
gibt ja welche die sagen wir umfragen
interessiere ich mich glaube ich nicht
sie sind schon ein 1 1 ein trend der da
ist und dieser trend dass ihr spürbar
auch bei der bevölkerung dagegen die
letzten wochen nicht nach oben insofern
hoffen jetzt sehr dass man diesen trend
brechen können auch nächste woche ist ja
dass erneut jetzt noch mal die
möglichkeit besteht die unterschiede
darzustellen es ist jetzt schon auch die
debatte noch einmal klar darüber welche
konstellationen stehen dahinter und es
wird auch noch einmal jedem richtig
bewusst und was ist dann am ende geht
was mich die ganze zeit im wahlkampf
bislang gestört hat ist ja da so so
ernste zeiten in denen wir eigentlich
leben corona ist nicht vorbei die
klimakrise fängt erst richtig an und die
internationalen probleme sind nicht dass
afghanistan wieder stärker im
mittelpunkt gerückt und gleichzeitig ist
der wahlkampf echt selten ernsthaft
gewesen also wer wohl lacht welche
lebenslauf oder wer wen wie oft lobt
insofern glaube ich sie mir jetzt
einfach einen entscheidenden
schlussphase ist wie im fußball wir
haben 80 minute jetzt braucht man die
zweite luft und gute werfen dann schauen
sie sich das wickeln drittel danken für
das gespräch sehr gerne
das hinter währende vor einer stunde
geführt viele berichte infos und videos
zum bundestagswahlkampf finden sie bei
uns natürlich auch immer online auf zdf
heute und jetzt macht erstmal ein
zweiter die taliban haben noch keine
neue regierung für afghanistan
vorgestellt aber sie stellen politische
forderungen auf etwa gegenüber
deutschland sie wollen offizielle
diplomatische beziehungen und
finanzielle hilfe wie ein taliban
sprecher der welt am sonntag sagte aus
afghanistan kommen widersprüchliche
berichte zur lage im umkämpften puncher
der einzigen provinz die die taliban
noch nicht kontrollieren sowohl die
taliban als auch die gegnerische miliz
von 8 mit massud melden erfolge für ihre
seite
in montenegro hat es bei der einführung
des dortigen oberhaupt der
serbisch-orthodoxen kirche krawalle
gegeben 20 polizisten und mindestens 30
protestierende wurden verletzt außerdem
etwa 14 personen festgenommen sie hatten
versucht die amtseinführung zu
verhindern
hintergrund sind politische und ethische
spannungen viele einwohner des
unabhängigen montenegros halten die
serbisch-orthodoxe kirche für von
serbien beeinflusst
im westafrikanischen guinea hat es
offenbar einen putschversuch von
spezialkräften des militärs gegeben auf
den straßen marschierten soldaten auf
auch heftige schusswechsel wurden
gemeldet im staatlichen fernsehen
verkündet er ein oberst die regierung
sei abgesetzt und die verfassung
ungültig der verbleib von präsident
go.de ist unklar der 83 jährige hatte
sich 2020 mit einer verfassungsänderung
eine dritte amtszeit ermöglicht und
damit massenproteste ausgelöst
nach einem messerangriff gestern in
berlin prüfen die ermittler mögliche
islamistische motive ein 29 jähriger
afghane soll eine landschaftsgärtnerin
mit stichen in den hals schwer verletzt
haben auch einen passanten der ihr zu
hilfe eilen wollte zum motiv hieß es
dass der mutmaßlich psychisch kranke
tatverdächtige sich daran gestört haben
soll dass die 58 jährige arbeitete
obwohl sie eine frau ist
zur krone situation in deutschland und
den aktuellen zahlen das robert koch
institut erfassten 10
1453 neue infektionen innerhalb von 24
stunden
2037 mehr als am vergangenen sonntag
weitere 21 todesfälle wurden gemeldet
die sieben tage incidents steigt auf
83,1
die zahlen steigen vollständig geimpft
sind hier erst 61 prozent virologen
waren dass das nicht genügt um die
vierte welle auszubremsen da könnte es
noch das ein oder andere detail gehen in
diesem winter während die aktuelle
pandemie noch im vollen gange ist
treffen sich in rom die
gesundheitsminister der g20-länder um
lehren für künftige pandemien zu ziehen
wie kann sich die welt besser
vorbereiten und wie lassen sich
impfstoffe gerechter verteilen
gesundheitsminister sparen sagte dass
die pandemie erst dann aufhören werde
wenn co wird überall mit impfungen
bekämpft werden kann ansonsten könnten
immer wieder neue mutationen entstehen
denn auch bei uns zu problemen führen
die erkenntnis ist da aber ausreichend
umgesetzt wurde das bisher nicht
beispiel afrika sie ist dort um kroner
und impfstoffe bestellt ist berichtet
susann von lojewski
warten auf die impfung pole pole langsam
langsam das sind afrikaner gewöhnt nur
in winzigen schritten geht es voran
manchmal nicht einmal das so ist das mit
dem tempo in afrika hunderte warten hier
im zweitgrößten krankenhaus nairobis
viele waren schon mehrmals da ist ein
bisschen schwierig ich war schon vor
zwei tagen da aber so aus dass nirgends
etwas auf lager ist ich war schon in
einem anderen krankenhaus aber da waren
die impfstoffe ausgegangen
daran hat auch die
moral verwaltet den mangel die
oberschwester verteilt die maschine für
die vier- millionen-metropole nairobi
heute ist ein guter tag sie hat genug
impfstoff für alle wartenden doch ob das
so bleibt
nach all den spenden die wir bekommen
haben wissen wir nicht was danach ist
wir haben 400.000 impfdosen bekommen wir
hoffen auf mehr aber wenn wir nicht mehr
kriegen dann haben wir ein problem
wieder und wieder beklagt die
weltgesundheitsorganisation die
ungerechte impfstoff verteilung weltweit
das die industrieländern zum dritten mal
impfen ein einziges ärgernis
[Musik]
57 prozent der bevölkerung europas sind
folge impft verglichen mit einer sehr
niedrigen quote von drei prozent in
afrika
wir müssen uns alle in erinnerung rufen
niemand ist sicher wenn ich die ganze
bevölkerung sicher ist
der impfstoff hätte das leben der
großmutter von doll weißenburger
vielleicht gerettet 19 tage lang lag sie
isoliert mit corona im krankenhaus
niemand durfte zu ihr oder
ich möchte ihnen gerne sagen geben sie
uns die impfstoffe so dass jeder und
jede geimpft werden
diese krankheit ist so gefährlich
das krankenhaus in dem dorf ist oma
starb liegt auf dem land am lake
victoria
seit einer woche gibt es hier keine
impfstoffe vielleicht nächste woche
vielleicht
wenn man verhindern kann dass die ganze
welt ein stadium der mutation erreicht
dann schützt man sich selbst wenn sie in
ihrem land weiterhin die dritte und
vielleicht die vierte impfung
verabreichen und die dritte welt ohne
impfung bleibt gehen sie ein großes
risiko ein
es sei nicht nur unfair sagen sie hier
es sei eine frage der intelligenz ohne
im gerechtigkeit gäbe es auch kein ende
der pandemie und
jetzt nochmal weitere nachrichten erst
mal zum bahn-streik pendler und reisende
die mit der deutschen bahn unterwegs
sind müssen sich auch morgen zum
wochenbeginn noch einmal auf erhebliche
einschnitte einstellen der streik der
gewerkschaft deutscher lokomotivführer
gdl soll noch bis in die nacht zum
dienstag andauern am wochenende fuhr nur
etwa jeder dritte fernzug und rund 60
prozent der s-bahnen fielen aus
bei den us open hat alexander zverev das
achtelfinale erreicht und da trifft die
deutsche nummer eins dann auf den
italiener wenig sinn in
der formel 1 fuhr max verstappen beim
großen preis der niederlande zu einem
souveränen heimsieg der 23 jährige red
bull fahrer setzte sich gegen wm
titelverteidiger lewis hamilton im
mercedes durch und übernahm von diesen
damit auch wieder die führung in der
gesamtwertung
und eine weitere medaillen für die
deutschen springreiter bei der heim-em
in riesenbeck andere team erholte sich
auf studie scharia gold und das gleich
bei seiner ersten wm-teilnahme nur einen
fehler dürfte sich der 46-jährige aus
plau am see erlauben und dabei blieb es
am ende auch für das deutsche team ist
es die erste goldmedaille im einzel seit
14 jahren
berlin kreuzberg und sven regener das
gehört untrennbar zusammen da so durch
spaziert scheint es ein bisschen als sei
die zeit stehen geblieben seien es noch
die 80er oder 90er jahre seine band
element of crime gehörte zum sound
dieser zeit dass regeln nicht nur
trompete spielen kann sondern auch
schreiben weiß man seit seinem roman
herr lehmann und bei dieser kleinen
spontan lesung in kreuzberg hat er sein
neues buch vorgestellt das trägt den
schönen titel glitter schnitter und
spielt natürlich auch in kreuzberg und
den 80ern christhard läpple über buch
und autor
willkommen zurück in die manns welt
berlin-kreuzberg anfang der 80er jahre
kult autor sven regener führt uns wieder
mitten rein ins bullerbü für aussteiger
und lebenskünstler hart an der mauer
aber immer auf der lauer nach dem echten
welten leben eine kostprobe
die ganze hippies in kreuzberg ging ja
schon jetzt auf die nerven dabei war sie
erst ein paar hundert meter durch den
quatsch bezirk zu fuß gelaufen ja wohl
zu fuß widerlich was man da zu sehen
bekam
wir sind mit sven regener in der madonna
verabredet dort ist die zeit
stehengeblieben moment mal die mauer
steht seit 30 jahren nicht mehr
und im sechsten lehmann roman glitter
schnitter geht es um freundschaft roms
und scheitern nur im alten west-berlin
als wäre nichts passiert warum das war
diese art von von freiheit und
unbefangenheit auch in derivate also an
ich so etwas wie die romantik eigentlich
im späten 18 frühen neunzehnten
jahrhundert ja einfach mal erst mal ist
alles so explodiert und ganz viel
plötzlich überall raus kommt auch viel
schrott aber was soll's irgendwo viel
gutes passiert passiert so viel du bist
jemand da ist er wieder frank lehmann
der junge träume aus bremen der heimat
von sven regener neu ist die band
kletter schnitter die drei jungs haben
einen plan sie träumen vom großen
auftritt auf dem golf citi neuss sie
verstärken sich mit saxofon lisa und
setzen auf einen sound des schlagzeugs
synthie und bohrmaschinen
es war eine seltsame zeit in westberlin
weil das diese aufbruchszeit zum zuge
der des punks und des post punks waren
diese ganzen neuen deutschen welle und
sollte und alle probierten einfach
irgendwas aus avantgardekunst war ein
ganz großes ding performance objekt uns
alles was man sich vorstellen kann war
irgendwie ein bug und jeder macht
überall mehr
regener erzählt von kreuzberg in seinen
besten momenten
aufregend anarchisch chaotisch längst
ist der szene kiez touristen hotspot und
tummelplatz für investoren aber dem
bandleader von element of crime
fasziniert vielmehr die frage aller 20
jährigen was willst du aus seinem leben
machen
wenn man 20 ist und war am abend zuvor
betrunken am nächsten tag ist nun
spätestens um 10 uhr und mittags isst
man spätestens wieder fit wenn man jetzt
30 jahre älter ist braucht man
vielleicht drei tage um sich davon zu
erholen das ist nun mal so dass der gang
der dinge da können wir nicht ändern
reginas alltagshelden haben stets
glasige augen nicola aber tausend träume
das ist peter schneiter der neue sven
regener ein brillantes stück zeitgeist
aus berlin der hauptstadt der hoffenden
und scheiternden
und jetzt wollt doch lieber unser
sonntäglicher wochenausblick kamera
safari an hat einige wichtige ereignisse
zusammengestellt die uns in den nächsten
tagen erwarten
[Musik]
am montag wird das urteil gegen die
weißrussische oppositionelle maria
callas nico war erwartet die 39-jährige
hatte die proteste gegen die wahl des
machthabers lukaschenko 2020 mit
angeführt sie wird beschuldigt die
nationale sicherheit untergraben zu
haben ihr drohen bis zu zwölf jahre haft
am dienstag soll das neue
infektionsschutzgesetz im bundestag
verabschiedet werden künftig soll die
hospitalisierung rate neuer wesentlicher
maßstab in der pandemie seien außerdem
arbeitgeber in betreuungs und
bildungseinrichtungen sollen künftig den
impfstatus abfragen dürfen
ebenfalls am dienstag wird die iaa ihre
pforten öffnen nicht mehr in frankfurt
sondern erstmals in münchen im zeichen
der e mobilität wird die weltgrößte
automobilmesse diesmal auch in teilen
der stadt zu sehen sein unter den
ausstellern diesmal auch
fahrradhersteller umweltverbände und
andere organisationen haben zu protesten
aufgerufen
am mittwoch wird der prozess gegen die
attentäter der pariser anschläge
eröffnet 2015 hatten die extremisten im
konzertsaal batak lohr und umgebung 130
menschen getötet 20 personen sind
angeklagt darunter der marokkanisch
stämmiger salah abdel einer der
mutmaßlichen haupttäter
und noch die wetteraussichten für morgen
für die sonne lokal aber auch zäher
nebel oder hochnebel am nachmittag im
nordwesten dichte wolken über weitgehend
trocken höchstwerte 20 bis 28 grad doch
in den nächsten tagen spätsommerlich
warm bei einer mischung aus sonne und
wolken am donnerstag im westen
aufkommende schauer und gewitter da 22
bis 29 grad
das war es von uns beiden an diesem
sonntagabend bevor wir gleich an den
sport ab geben noch der hinweis auf la
traviata in anschluss eine gefeierte
neuinszenierung aus der arena in verona
und um 0.30 gibt es dann die nächste
heute express
[Musik]